ouais
vous ne trouvez pas que la fin est
injuste
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
petit couac est mort d'une overdose
[Musique]
boostée de la société
le pao il ya bien venu seulement
mollement coma puis il est vrai une
partie souffrir dans l'ensemble ça fait
[Musique]
mais on vient
comme ça c'est ça nous avons
le plus important c'est colette mois
rodin place pour donner
quelques pas au droit que rim
[Musique]
oui
à
regarde comment les mots j'avoue ça là
bas raconte et du temps suffisant par
contre en reviendra plus il ya que des
des usa se saoule
oui
oui au sein du tsoup
tout voyage
[Musique]
à apple haïti comme étalon
on fait ça mais ça donne
[Musique]
oui
tout
[Musique]